my ass or something right now and is it
real question if if like people in this
country had a disease right and they're
always my favorite disease no the only
and the only way to cure is if you suck
my dick would you suck my date I'm
talking about billions of people bro
well it brings people what what do mean
what we said basically you said we just
suck my dick I'm just saying though
there's some sort of disease in the
country right do you really ever take up
but you have like a kazoo
would you we just suck it though to save
millions of people's lives or work
here's what I would do I wouldn't suck
it yeah but if someone else sucked it
you know and it was late late at night I
might smell their breath really fast oh
you do that know what you're probably a
hundred people maybe yeah but I'm one of
those hundred then that's how I made you
well ask you ask the reverse would I
suck your dick for [ __ ] for billions
yeah what do they ask me would you suck
my dick for a little for for 70 80 bucks
what that's it 70 80 bucks save the
world well yeah yeah round it up to a
hundred what about for a cheat code on
on that bejeweled game you play a river
put about four mystery levels would you
suck dick for mister what's a game
called whatever it's like bejeweled or
something yeah yeah man so yeah I guess
I would then okay yeah why are you so
aggressive dude well right now I don't
like bet yeah you're like what up you're
like Beijing like back of it Oh Fupa
alert ass
hmm look like a sick animal you like fat
meals or what so weird I'm gonna say
this but that looks a lot more shaved
you see I shave I know I've been shaving
it as of late yeah usually it's a bush
yeah look oh wow that is crazy it looks
like it needs to be dry
dr. Pipo Popi
[Music]